can white win in this position in my
article in chess.com
i looked at 10 types of positions where
chess engines don't necessarily
understand the positions better than the
strongest human players
now under normal circumstances the best
chess engines are about a thousand elo
points stronger
than the best human players so these are
certainly special types of positions
that demonstrate some key elements of
human creativity
and ingenuity now in this position a
chess engine will claim that white is
easily winning after all white has an
extra queen
two rooks and two knights but that same
chess engine will not be able to suggest
a winning plan for white in fact
humans are often better in closed
positions and in positions with
long-term planning elements
here the long-term plan is needed to win
this game
let's break things down now first off
the white knights cannot move at all
they are totally restricted by the pawns
also the white king can move but it's
not clear what the king's movement will
accomplish
the rooks can also move and they can
tempt the black pawns to capture them
and that would allow white to break
through by giving back a little bit of
material
but as long as the black pawns never
ever capture a rook
then it's also not clear what moving
these rooks and offering them to the
ponds will accomplish
it turns out that the only winning plan
here is to play queen a2
now queen a2 threatens queen takes b3
which will allow white to break through
but in this position you can't play
queen a2
because after pawn takes a2 black is
going to make a queen on
a1 and that queen is actually stronger
than all of white's
very clustered forces the queen will
actually come back here
and black is actually the one to win the
game
therefore queen a2 must be prepared
the way to prepare it is to maneuver
your rook around to c2
once the rook gets around to c2 you're
ready to play queen a2
and that will win the game however that
requires
a lot of preparation here we can start
with king over to d1 we're going to
shuffle the king around and then swing
the rook over to e2
so it can get over to c1 we're also
going to need the h1 rook as well
because it's going to need to help and
defend the first rank once we sacrifice
our queen
so now the king can go back to d1 and
the rooks have made this
orbit over to the c and e files as they
danced around
the white king now with things in
position we are ready
to play rook c2 first again black is
never in a position to capture a rook
because that will unblock the pawn
structure
in the board and allow white to break
through so king b5 continuing to try and
sit
and wait king over to c1 king back and
now
queen a2 finally after 16 moves of
preparation
we are ready for this move now because
of queen takes b3 here on the horizon
black must capture on a2 and the
critical move
is now pawn to b4 in this position white
is of course threatening to capture this
pawn so it's time for that pawn to
promote
and after the promotion you have rook to
b2
this move traps the queen here on a1
now the critical question once we've
achieved all of this
is what happens if black continues to
shuffle with the king
how do we make progress well the answer
is that we can just shuffle
black doesn't have any moves but king
moves and so eventually black is going
to run out of king moves
and is not going to be able to continue
to block the b
pawn which marches up the board and will
eventually become
a new queen and that will allow white to
easily win the game
and deliver check mate this next
position features some of the same ideas
as
in the first example that example showed
us a position where white was up oodles
of material but it was very difficult to
find a winning plan
here we see a position where white must
go down material
but will be able to hold with trap piece
and fortress concepts
the computer is not very good at
understanding trapped pieces
and fortresses in the position we see
that white has two pieces
under attack the rook on a6 and the
bishop on c5
there is no way to save both of these
pieces but
it is not necessary to save the pieces
to save the game
white can play the absolutely brilliant
rook to c6 here the rook is defending
the bishop and the only way to really
push for a win
is to take that rook now white plays
pawn to b4
the idea here is to trap the rook on b5
it can go nowhere and white is able to
shuffle the king between c7
and c8 movements from the black king and
black bishop will change nothing
however there is a second stage here
eventually the rook is going to
sacrifice itself
for the bishop on c5 in that case
isn't the extra bishop that black has
enough to win
it turns out no there's still a fortress
in the resulting position for white
let's see how that can develop
so black is going to encroach with the
king and shift the bishop around and
eventually
sacrifice on c5 again remaining a piece
up
in this position however here there's no
way to get the white king
out of the corner and there's no way to
activate this black king which is
restricted by the pawns
and the white king of course the bishop
also can never
attack the pawns that are on dark
squares so black is able to shuffle a
bit and try to
make progress by including the bishop on
a6 so that the king cannot go to c8
and the bishop can even come around the
other side of the board
however as the black king approaches and
tries to kick out the white king so he
can get around
to get at the white pawns eventually
there is
a stalemate defense and this holds the
game
you can try for a long time but against
the best defense you'll never be able to
win
with the extra bishop this next example
comes from a human game it's anish gary
vs maxine rajstein from the european
club cup of 2012.
the following sequence is one of my
favorites and i covered it in my series
on best chess moves
about two months ago it's also this
example that inspired me to look for
more positions
in which humans were able to make
clearer sense of the position
than chess engines so here what did gary
do
well he found a beautiful winning plan
pawn to a4
faced with the loss of a pawn on the
queen side but captures on a4
and now gary plays rook takes c5
he's giving up two pawns in a position
in which there's not much material left
surely black is better or at least not
worse in this position right
well what matters is the power of this
bishop
and the immortality of the pin on the
knight on f6
that pin is eternal gary emphasized that
fact with the move
pawn to f4 now white is able to win
simply by shuffling the bishop between
a1 and c3
and eventually black must move the king
and lose the knight on f6
there are a few ways to win at this
point but my
favorite winning idea is really to
emphasize the zug's wing
so after pawn to a3 you play bishop a1
and as black tries to get ready to play
g5 you just let black play g5
and then you play pawn to f5 emphasizing
that black can do nothing in this
position
after black runs out of pawn moves
eventually black will move the king
and lose the knight on f6 and the game
this is another human game sekulsky
verse ravinsky from the soviet union
1938 in fact pages of analysis have been
dedicated to this game
but will condense everything for this
video here
black is trying desperately to draw away
the defense that russian players call
the mad peace there's a good chance
you've seen the idea before
if white here makes a queen or a rook
then black is going to perpetually check
with the black rook eventually white
needs to capture and that produces
stalemate
now computers aren't very good at
appreciating this kind of concept
unless there's a clear perpetual check
on the horizon
the basic problem for the computer is
that in every single position they're
calculating the rook's
sacrifice and saying can i take that ah
no it's stalemate
but a human player goes one time all
right i can never take the rook
and can i ever get out of this and we're
able to see in a lot of positions that
there really
is no way to escape all the checks and
as a result
we're going to have to concede a draw
well how does white get away from this
clever defense from black it turns out
not to be so simple
for example if you do nothing or kind of
try to be patient in the position
then black is able to come back and stop
promotion
and as you try to make patient progress
black always has
good ideas to give up the rook and the
bishop to draw
once again by stalemate also if you
under promote to a knight here then the
knight basically ends up trapped
black is going to sacrifice the rook for
the night and once again
stalemate so it turns out that the
only winning idea here is to
underpromote to a bishop
of course this is incredibly rare
but it's the right move in this position
now black is still close to achieving a
draw with the mad piece
but with clever play white can win for
example
rook c8 going after that bishop bishop
back to e4
and now the clever bishop c6 the idea is
to give up this bishop because
if it's on the board then you're not
really dealing with stalemate defenses
as
long as white doesn't go to the back
rank here you of course can't take with
the rook because the trade of rooks
produces an immediate stalemate
so you take with the bishop but now
black is able to try again for the mad
peace defense
trying desperately to sacrifice the rook
force white to take
or concede basically a perpetual check
and the game will be drawn
however here bishop a4 stopping the
sacrifice of the rook
rook over to e8 trying for new checks
notice that the rook is hanging and
that's not relevant at all because
you're never taking that
king a3 rook back to a8 saying i'm still
going to sacrifice myself
and now the end rook to e6
a really beautiful beautiful and
brilliant winning idea
the point now is that there is no more
stalemate defense
because you will always have the idea to
capture the rook
and capturing the rook is not enough to
secure a draw because white has too many
strong pawns and also this outside past
b-pawn white is able to approach and
here's a nice winning line
you approach with your king and your
bishop you get ready to push this pawn
down
and if black captures then the back rank
is vulnerable and white is able to force
pawn promotion winning the game very
very beautiful incredible stuff this
next position
was composed by lazard now if you've
heard of lazard it's probably because
he's relatively famous for having lost
the shortest master chess game of all
time we're going to replay that on the
board
at the side but in addition to having
that dubious honor he also composed
many incredible and beautiful chess
studies like this one
i would argue that this one in
particular is one of the most beautiful
chess studies
of all time to draw this game where
white is down
a lot of material you need to find an
incredible fortress defense that holds
the game
the computer will insist that black is
winning but in fact
there is no way to break through now the
first move
is not so difficult to find 94 check and
the point here is that if the knight is
captured
then you have checkmate in one a very
pretty checkmate
but black can play king h4 here and how
is white to continue
if you play bishop b1 check then g3
allows the king to maneuver
there are no more checkmates and no more
stalemates black wins easily
but after king h4 white has the
incredible
knight to g3 an absolutely brilliant
move that sacrifices the knight in two
ways
and threatens knight to f5 checkmate
of course the king cannot capture
because that again walks into the idea
of bishop e1 checkmate
however the pawn can capture and it
looks like that should easily win the
game right
well no incredibly white can play bishop
to b6
and this is the critical fortress the
bishop will shuffle along this diagonal
and no matter what black does there's no
way to win
if you check on the first rank then just
bishop back to g1
the bishop blocks and if you keep the
queen here
then you just have a stalemate and if
you sacrifice the queen for the bishop
and say all right i'm just going to win
with these connected passers over here
then you can't actually win because the
black kink is totally trapped and can
never involve itself
in the game it's really quite stunning
additionally you can't really make
progress
in the position by ever ever pushing
these pawns even if you
let off the stalemate because white will
always capture the pawns that they
advance
and when the king the queen captures on
this diagonal
you again have stalemate because the
queen will control g1
let's look at what is considered the
most beautiful continuation in the study
that is queen to f8 stopping knight f5
here
and now bishop e1 threatening knight f5
with double check
and check mate so finally black must
capture the knight on g3
pawn takes g3 and bishop to f2
the bishop is offered twice but both
captures lead to stalemate and again
once you get to this diagonal
you have a fortress there are some ideas
to try to break through
for example you can give up these pawns
again
if you capture you have stalemate and
eventually you can try to win by playing
queen f2
this does force bl a white to capture
the queen here on f2 but after bishop
takes f2
pawn takes white finally has g3 check
here
and whether you capture with the king or
play king h3
it is again stalemate white has
incredibly held
this position i hope that you've enjoyed
all of these incredible examples i
encourage you if you like these
positions to check out the article
which has a lot more examples also
if you want to see some incredible
examples of computer ingenuity
then do check out our playlist with
incredible computer chess games